abone ol
ama biz insanlar hayatın merkezine
yalnızca kendimizi koyma yerindeyiz dik
Hatta Öyle ki her şeyi tüm canlılığı
Hatta cansızlığı bile ancak kendi
varlığımız üzerinden anlamaya çalışırız
Hatta ancak öyle anlam kazandığını
düşünürsünüz her şeyi insan üzerinden
insan ihtiyaçları üzerinden tanımlarız
bunun sonucunda dünyanın yüküne sahip
olduğumuz egemenliğine sahip olduğumuz
anlayışı da aslında biz öyle bir noktaya
getirir ki canlılığın bitkilerin
türlerinin yok olması doğal akışında
değil yalnızca insanın akışında olmaya
başlar baktığınızda kötü bir şey
yaptığımızda hemen hayvanların mesela
trafikte kavga edilir ve bay hayvan diye
bir tepki verilir türler öküz eşek ayı
gibi argo ulaştı
bu tür lükten ve var oldukları kapsamdan
dışarı çıkar ama öte yandan da iyi bir
şey olduğunda birbirine yardım ettiğinde
baksana ya insanlık ölmemiş tiz yani
sokaktan işyerinden okuldan akademiye
kadar her yerde insanın ayrımını Hatta
insanın ayrımından daha çok insanın
üstünlüğünü bütün türlere karşı olan
üstünü görmemiz mümkündür bunu Aslında
açıklayan çok güzel bir kelime var
antroposantrizm bu antik yunan'dan
geliyor Antrepo kelimesi insan demek
satron Kent rumdan geliyor Bu da Merkez
demek yani insanların evrendeki en
önemli varlık olduğu en biricik varlık
olduğu inancı bu bakışla yalnızca
dünyayı insani değerler ve insani
kavramlarla anlamak mümkündür tabi bunun
sonucunda da bu bize yalnızca kibir ve
kontrolsüz bir güç vermektedir
Ya aslında birazcık daha açacak olursak
antroposantrizm ile birlikte Türkçülük
dediğimiz bir kavramdan bahsederiz
Türkçülük de canlı bireylere yalnızca
ait oldukları türden ötürü farklılık
ayrımcılık Sömürgecilik yapmaktır Yani
bunun bir örneği Evde köpek beslerken
karşınızda bir et yi olmanızdır Bu bir
türkçülüktür Ben firma ailesi ile
ilgileniyorum kuyruksuz maymunlardan
Özellikle de şempanzelerle e çalışıyorum
Prima dediğimizde aklımıza ne geliyor
kırmak dediğimizde bunun içinde prospero
simyaların lemurların Eski dünya
maymunları nın yeni dünya' maymunlarının
kuyruksuz maymunların ve insanların
olduğu kocaman bir biyolojik gruptan
bahsediyoruz bunun içinde farklı
taksonomik sınıflar neredeyse 270 lira
300 tane de farklı tür var ya ne zaman
ben
bu haberle ilgili bir şey söylesem akla
gelen ilk soru sarı nokta eksi izle
dinlen Tabi öyle bir jenerasyon da da
öyle bir dönemde yaşıyoruz ki popüler
kültürün merkezinde hayvanlar
oluşturuyor yani hayvanlarla ilgili
diyalogları farklı canlılarla ilgili
diyalogları filmlerden komik boklar da
birçok farklı yere kadar Instagram
dostlarından Birçok yerde görmemiz
mümkün Peki canım tarafta elbise
baktığımız zaman ne görüyoruz aslında
insan bakışına insan baskısına karşı
isyan eden ve egemenliğini kurmak için
ayaklanan bir tür kuyruksuz maymun
ihtirasını görüyoruz Tabi buna
baktığımız zaman da bunları yaparlarken
yine insan nasıl fları üzerinden insan
hareketleriyle ve yalnızca onlara Yani
insana İthafen hareket ettiklerini
görüyoruz Bu birleştirin öte yandan
farklı başka bir gerçeklikle bak
Ya aslında filmde genetikleriyle
oynanmış genetik müdahale yüzünden
insanlaştırma mış olma çabasıyla veya
yüzünden bu hareketler Ee ulaştıklarında
bu hareketleri sahip ettiklerini
görüyoruz Halbuki doğayı kendi akışına
bıraktığımız zaman illaki bizim yani
insanların geçtiği yoldan geçmek zorunda
değildir Doğa İlla insan vasıfları
üzerinden insana ayet ya da insani
hareketler GTA bir ettiğiniz şeyleri
yapmak zorunda değildir peki buradan
nereye geliyorum konuşmamın başta
insansı maymun oldu Tam da bu yüzden bu
başlığı seçtim çünkü insansı maymun İsmi
bile yalnızca bizim benzetme lerimiz
üzerinden insanı tanımladıktan sonra bir
atıfta bulunmaktan geliyor Ancak bu
maalesef Türkçe'nin azizliğine uğramış
bir durum çünkü ev kelimesinin karşılığı
maalesef Türkçede yapımı benim kuyruksuz
maymun olan
bu ettiğim Sony Tosta elbise de geçen
Eyüp kuyruksuz maymun vardır ancak buna
karşılık birçok dilde farklı bir kelime
Varken biz insansın var ya kullanırız
Dolayısıyla onların varlığını yine kendi
üzerimizden anlamaya başlarız Bu da
insansı maymun ismini Aslında yine
antropomorfik bir yapısına işaret eder
Daha iyi daha doğrusu Bizler daha iyi
bir kelime bulana kadar insansı maymun
yerine kuyruksuz maymun kelimesini
kullanmaya devam edeceğiz Peki kuyruksuz
maymunlar kimdir bunlar nelerdir diye
bunları bir Bakmak istedim
Bu kutuyu orangutanlar kuyruksuz maymun
Ailesi evrimi orangutan larla başlar
Tabii bundan daha öncesinde birleştire
yüklediğimiz bir kategori var Ama bugüne
iplerden söz etmeye çalışacağım ben size
burada bir orangutan görüyoruz kuyruksuz
Ailesi ormanına Ailesi orangutanla
başlıyor
abone ol
ya amca çalışıyorum Daha sonrasında
birazcık daha tanıdık olduğunu düşündüm
Goriller geliyor
bu Türk topla elbise en çok karşımıza
çıkan şempanzeler
bu ve kuyruksuz maymun Ailesinin son
üyesi de ve en son keşfedilen çok uzun
süreler hatta çok yakın bir zamana kadar
şempanze zannedilen bonobo zaman
bahsediyoruz Biz insan karşılaştırmaları
yaparlarken diyelim her şeyi şempanzeler
üzerine yapıyoruz burada ayrı bir soru
eğer bana bunları daha önceden Tanışmış
olsaydık nasıl karşılaştırmalar yapardık
maalesef bunları anlatacak bir süre mi
yok ama kuyruksuz maymunlardan size
biraz bahsetmek istiyorum kuyruksuz
maymunlar nedir kuyruksuz maymun Ailesi
Bu gördüğünüz dört tane prim adı içerir
anlayacağınız Tahmin ettiğiniz gibi
kuyrukları yoktur yüzlere neredeyse
çıplaktır bir kulakları Gördüğünüz üzere
yuvarlaktır ve çoğunlukla kulakları da
tüysüzdür baş parmakları diğer
parmaklardan daha kısadır Ben de ayak
parmakları kavrama yeteneğine sahip
bu kokudan daha çok görme odaklanırlar
ve bu görme uzak sayesinde bir derinlik
algıları vardır iki ayak üzerinde yürüme
kabiliyetleri vardır insanlar dışında
kolları bacaklarından daha uzundur
buraya insan fotoğrafı koymadım bunun
gibi birçok ortak özellikleri vardır
tabi Hepsi kendi içinde farklı yeme
düzenlenen yaşama habitatların a kendi
karakter özelliklerine ve türün
getirdiği Farklı özelliklere sahiptir
Peki ben birazcık şempanzeler den
bahsetmeye çalışacağım size şempanzeler
kimdir şempanzeler Ne yaparlar
şempanzeler 15 ila 120 kişilik gruplar
halinde hep beraber doğada yaşarlar
şempanzeleri Afrika'da budur Özellikle
de Orta Afrika şempanzelerin yaşadığı
doğal bölgedir bir şempanzelerin
bu operasyonları vardır bir farklı
cinsleri vardır farklı mimikleri vardır
aslında şu ana kadar en çok konuşulan
ardıma bizi insanla şempanze den ayıran
şey nedir oldu her şeyi denedik ilk
başta dedik ki yahu insan alet kullanan
canlı o zaman Mendel Maker dedik insana
daha sonra baktık ki şempanzeler davet
kullanıyor Tamam o zaman başka bir şey
bulalım insan empati yapan canlıdır daha
sonra farklı tür empati yaptığını bulduk
alet kullandığını bulduk sosyalleştirme
bulduk daha farklı dinamikleri olduğunu
bulduk ama neler bulursak bulalım hala
2020 yılında bizi şempanze den ayıran
üstümüzü kurmanızı sağlayan şey nedir
bunun peşindeyiz ve şu andaki en büyük
argüman da değildir tabi Burada diye
nasıl tanımladığımız bil dediğimizde
aklımıza ne geldiği önemlidir dilwali
Sen farklı mıdır dil dediğimizde vücut
dili de burada yer
bu Çünkü dediğim gibi şempanzelerin
birbirleriyle anlaşmasında jestleri
mimikleri duruşları çene oyna atışları
birçok farklı dinamik vardır şempanzeler
dolduktan sonra 6-7 yıl annelerine bağlı
yaşarlar önce annenin göğsünde yaşarlar
sonra birçok fotoğrafta falan
göreceğiniz gibi annenin sırtına
çıkarlar kimi zaman daha sonra yere
inerler birlikte yürürler birlikte
seyahat ederler Sevinç öfke kızgınlık
depresyon bunun gibi duyguları vardır
şempanzelerin Hep bitti olduğunu
düşünürüz Çünkü birbirlerini tımara
derler asla şempanzelerle bitti yoktur
şempanzeler sosyalleşmek için Tıpkı
bizim birbirimizi gördüğümüz de
sarıldığımız kucaklaştığı mız gibi ya da
Seninle vakit geçirmek istiyorum tür
altında birçok farklı duygu da olabilir
Bunları göstermek için birbirini tımar
ederler yaşam alanları suya Yakın olsa
da yüzme zler
ama bilmezler ama yine de yağmur
dansları vardır Buna bakmanızı tavsiye
ederim doğada kırk yıl Esaret altında
Ortalama 55 60 yıl kadar yaşayabilirler
oynadıklarını gülerler gıdıklanır lar
birbirlerine gıdıklar korktuklarında ya
da sinirlendiklerinde tüyene dikenler
Hatta bir tehdit olduğunda kendini daha
büyük göstermek için bütün tüyler diken
diken alır bir her birinin ayrı
karakteri Vardır her birinin ayrı ayrı
kendine ait kişisel özelliği vardır
sorarlar Ya bu şempanzeleri nasıl ayıp
ediyorsun birbirimizi nasıl Evet
ediyorsa Tıpkı onları da bunun gibi
ayırt edebiliyoruz en son olaraktan çok
da uzatmadan şempanzeler evcil hayvanlar
değillerdir Şen fazla yer doğanın bir
parçasıdır ve doğanın parçası olarak da
kalması kalmalıdır bugün baktığımızda
şempanzeler nesli tükenen hayvan
kategorisinde
bu işte maalesef doğada 172 bin lira 300
bin adet şempanze kaldığını düşünüyorlar
Peki benim adım ne ya da bu konuşmanın
amacını benim umudum şempanzeleri kendi
He evrimleşmiş karikatür lerimiz olarak
görmemiz Biz şempanzeleri oldukları
türler üzerinden anlamamız bütün türleri
için geçerli anlamaya çalışmamız ya
kadar ki Doğada bir kelime olacak
yorumlamaya çalışmamız şempanzelerin ve
birçok türün bugün doğasını yok ediyoruz
Prima türlerinin yüzde 60'ının Habit
Atını yok ettik bilen ve bunlar insan
faaliyetine karşı savunmasız lar insanın
küresel ve yerel pazar taleplerini
endüstriyel tarımın gelişmesi petrol ve
gaz sondajları primatların yaşadıkları
yerlerin affetmekten iklim krizi
primatları ve bütün türleri hemen hemen
bütün türleri de
bu oradan etkilemekte şempanzenin
yalnızca küçük bir kısmı korunaklı
yerlerde yaşamakta hala yardıma muhtaç
birçok şempanze var hala korunmaya
muhtaç birçok türü var şempanzelerin ve
türlerin Aslında şempanzelerin
primatları ve diğer türlerin ortadan
kalkması durumunda yani neslinin
tükenmesi durumunda neler kaybedeceğimiz
anlamak için okumamız gerekiyor çünkü
ancak okuduğumuz da anlayabiliriz ancak
bilgilendirmenizi anlayabiliriz ve ancak
ilgilendiğiniz harekete geçebiliriz o